this is the second lecture is part two I
call it more like Oda Bobby Fischer and
to explain what Bobby Fischer's impact
on myself personally was in the world at
large and specifically in chess and the
game in the first lecture we had looked
at game one of his 1992 return match
against Boris Spassky where I
demonstrated that for 50 consecutive
moves in a row Bobby played flawlessly
without mistakes every move was right on
and how his play was like this smooth
chain of progressive moves all leading
to a finish where he had total
domination okay like this extraordinary
a style if you will okay so here's old
man Bobby Fischer that Boris Spassky has
just put down and it's game 2 and I'm in
like open mouths astonishment in Seattle
still recovering from game 1 and the
fact that Bobby played 50 flawless moves
after being absent from the world of
chess for 20 years I just couldn't
imagine how rusty I might have been so
for this game I had a problem I'm not
sure if it was my problem I kind of
think it was but it might have been
problem on the Yugoslavs ID that somehow
in terms of a telephone connection so
you and I are talking on the phone we
have a five-minute conversation the line
gets cut piece of cake we hang up will
will recall it yeah did you hang up no I
didn't hang ok the lines are movable
blah well with a fax machine
if it's getting information and the line
gets cut it's like the facts
ding del Sol because we're you're the
whole office in Seattle was like you
know everybody's like eyes on the fax
machine in the chess board I have
established a telephone hook up with
George stefanov itch the journalist who
is in the press ENTER and it was like
okay this is Howard okay
Spassky has played queen pawn Bobby of
course has played Kings Indian defense
Bobby uh provoked Boris Boris has
sacrificed upon Bobby took the pawn of
course Boris defended well but gave
exchange to win back pawn Bobby took
exchange and now I think he's winning
here like 2-0 I mean this is like
unbelievable how is he doing this you
know I think is it is it clearly visible
on your screen as it is on my screen
Bobby Fischer's rating is 2785 do you
see that boris baskis readiness 2560 the
the rating of Bobby Fischer was his
rating at the time he stopped playing
chess I believe at one moment after he
defeated bent Larsen six to nothing
Bobby had an unpublished rating of 2820
at a time I believe that the world
champion didn't have a rating of 2700
goes to show here who like what bobby
was doing to the competition of course
garry kasparov
he was the first to break the 2800 class
but let's be fair his nearest rivals
whether they were carp off or Korchnoi
or Kramnik or whoever it was that he was
playing against we're really really
really close to him so if he drew he
didn't necessarily lose a lot of rating
points
I believe I just have to check this that
when Bobby Fischer won the World
Championship 12 and a half seven and a
half including one forfeit he lost
rating points he lost rating points he
was supposed to beat him by a greater
margin to to preserve his rating okay so
he Bobby Fischer his inherited his old
rating from the time he quit okay Kings
Indian defense and Boris in those days
uh and not just in those days but aim
and a lot of his career plays played the
same ish variation against the Kings
Indian and if you look at the same issue
iation from whites point of view it's
very aesthetically pleasing this is a
nice structure look at that that's kind
of pretty and the bishop is going to
come to e3 where it can't be harassed by
the knight Bishop comes to e3 Bishop
comes the d3 Knight comes to e2 castles
and it's very aesthetically pleasing but
I like what
Grand Master Edward gue Feld said to me
about such moves he says do you talk to
your pieces
buuuut on well yes I do but don't tell
anybody he says when you play the move
f2 f3 did you ask the gentleman on June
1 yeah what he is thinking that you've
taken away his best square so Kings
Indian defense players they try to talk
down the same ish because they really
don't like playing against it so they'll
point out to you like your guys very
unhappy and to you what makes you fun
see if I this is almost a kind of a
psychological decision I think many
people who want to play the move c5
first preface it with castles because
it's sort of like it's an offer do you
want to go into the endgame yeah do you
want it to trade queens and cost me
castling and go into an ending normally
people normally speaking when you're
black you don't like to make such an
offer to your opponent they might accept
it to begin with on the other hand if
your approach to the same issue to play
against the same issue is to play with
the move c5 the problem from whites
blacks point of view is if you castle
Bishop e3 and now you play the move c5
it is a pawn sacrifice and that goes
like this with or without trading Queens
and Gary Kasparov has proven in his
practice that the pawn sacrifice is not
dangerous for black then he gets a good
play for his pawn but it's not to
everybody's taste that they want to
sacrifice a pawn gambit upon I mean as
black so Bobby play c5 right away and
Boris decided to take Bobby up on his
offer traded Queens Bishop e3
in the immortal words of dr. nickel I'm
in M gift me your font gift me upon
Bobby says name Knight b8 Knight f6 d7
which is a very strange kind of
unconventional move to amateur eyes
beginner eyes what are you doing with
this move knight on f6 to d7 why aren't
you playing knight on b8 to d7 isn't
isn't it so yes sir isn't it so that you
shouldn't move your pieces too often in
the opening and isn't it so that this
Knight is undeveloped and this Knight is
developed yes yes yes yes but these guys
are the guys who write the rules
remember these guys are the guys who
write the books and basically what Bobby
is saying in this position is this
knight on f6 maybe Development is not
effective the knight on f6 blocks this
Bishop sty agonal and maybe this Knight
has better uses maybe if you're not
watching too closely it might jump to c6
and as well as the d4 square yes
yes yeah you're the this long diagonal
is not about to be challenged by the
bishop on e3 that's right yes well maybe
he does that say maybe he does maybe
this Bishop looks it's a beauty
but I if you give me a free hand to let
me do what I want I would be very
interested in Bishop takes B takes b6
Bishop a six-night c6 Knight a5 and gift
me your part okay so he may on the one
hand be intimating I'm ready to take
this Knight on the other hand he may be
saying hey be careful I might occupy the
d4 square Boris Spassky says I don't
want you to thank my knight I will
protect my my knight b7 b6 again this
move kind of needs some explanation and
unfortunately it's only after many many
many games of Grandmaster practice do we
understand that what a black would love
to play the move knight c6 castles and
now what black would like to do is play
the movie 75 and stick the knight on d4
yeah then it's great you're you you
white will stick his knight on d5 the
position will be balanced and so on the
problem of course is that 'if I've is
running into Bishop takes e5 there's a
pin on the D file
so black is going to need to keep that
pawn on c5 protected b6 castles now
comes the next phase from whites point
of view he's not very happy this pieces
look okay but you talk to your Bishop on
f1 there's a bishop on what Ln f1 very
happy no the Bishop says hey man I've
got nothing to look at
oh I know what I should do says white I
should play g3 with the idea perhaps of
Bishop h3 or I should play G 3 F 4 e 5
and put my Bishop on g2 which would be
multi-purpose first it would close this
diagonal and open this diagonal so we
have this move now again from blacks
point of view it's very sensible to
think in terms of knight c6 Knight d4
the problem with knight c6 is white
first plays f4 to make the move e5 less
attractive then he's going to play g3
and then he's going to play Bishop g2 so
Bobby has a following setup in mind and
will see it unfold in front of us with
Knight a six he's thinking that in his
mind's eye the knight would be wrong on
this square he's anticipating white
playing g3 f4 e 5 he wants his Bishop to
go to b7 and have an unobstructed view
of this diagonal furthermore he's a
little bit worried about his king where
should my king go he's in his mind I
Bobby is determined that his the best
position for his King would be
the e7 square which by definition means
we got to move the pawn on e6 when we
play ecigs King e7 we've got to be a
little bit concerned of 95 to d6 and the
knight would be really good on d6 so
with this move Knight a six Bobby is
going to play Knight c7 cutting up
Knight b5 following it up with e six
King e7 Bishop d7 let's see how the game
unfolds g3 we understand this move
because the bishops been crying and
shouting and let me into the game come
on coach let me and then I can play
Knight c7 f4 e 6 Bishop h3 now White has
to decide what is his ideal setup I
think everybody everybody would like to
play the movie 4 but then after Bishop
d7 a tempo against the rook the rook
would go here blacks King would go here
and the best White has is simply trading
bishops okay white does enjoy an
advantage in space but it will be very
hard to convert that to any kind of a
serious advantage with the move Bishop
h3 Boris takes the a completely
different approach Boris's approach is
look Joker you've moved your king I'm
going to try to keep as many pieces on
the board as I possibly can and I'm
going to try to attack your King and the
way I'm going to do that is I'm going to
play rook H 1 to F 1 followed by f7 f5
blast open this diagonal and blast open
the F file as well as the D file okay
King e7 rook f1 h6 okay
so somebody help me out here what's the
idea of h6 what is the idea of h6 don't
all shout out at once yes b4 to DC also
yes you had also an idea why he played
h6 you you were thinking about f5 and
then yes right so one of the one of the
ideas is that black can very well see
it's almost like a telegraph punch right
that white wants to play f5 white wants
to capture the pawn on g6 capture the
pawn on g6 and play a move like Knight
f4 when both the e6 as well as g6 pawns
so
bobbies move h6 as you've correctly said
is that after f5 his intention is
displayed g5 and to take the square F
for away from the night on e 2 and at
the same time when white plays the move
f5 isn't that a lovely square for the
black knight Knight Black Knight comes
to e5 darn it Boris has to change
because f5 would miss its mark final
point of F at h6 is that if fi does come
we also have to be worried about a
Bishop g5 check right so you take away
bat a possibility
so II five so now this is kind of cool
from from blacks point of view from
blacks point of view he doesn't have to
worry about G 4 and F 5 anymore because
the pawn is now on e4 on the other hand
alert
you know spoiler alert Knight e4 to d6
would be devastating but white would
have a huge strategic advantage if he
could do that so we stopped him yeah
Bishop d7 G 4 at this moment I can only
imagine that Spassky was feeling quite a
bit frustrated his attempts to keep the
pieces on and to attack the King in the
center Soviet chess school you know you
don't keep your King in the center we
will open the center and get your king
well Bobby is defying the conventional
wisdom he's keep he's kept his King in
the center and he's challenging Boris
Spassky to do something about it
Boris went g4 again with a very
straightforward idea that he he's he's
going to play it f5 even at the cost of
sacrificing his pawn on e5 rook da we
all understand developing our forces
Knight g3 warming up for the big punch
of f4 f5 and once again with the idea of
94 and Knight coming to d6 what should
Bobby do
rook f8 so the idea behind the move rook
f8 how are we planning on meeting 94 if
the night goes to e4 and then to d6 you
don't need a map to understand it it's
tough
yes good man f5 ok when we play a move
like f5 two thoughts should come through
your mind the first one is could white
sacrifice a piece in other words f5g f
GF Bishop takes f5 e takes f5 night
takes f5 check King moves you have to
you have to calculate the second one you
have to calculate is what about fi takes
takes Knight h5 where are you going to
move your bishop are you willing to
trade give up your minor pair and allow
your opponent's to win the two bishops
right idea right idea just go to f6 so
the idea of Bobby's here with the move
f6 is very simple this Knight coming to
d6 is simply too powerful so we stop it
that's all
if white trades Knight takes the move g5
we don't worry about because the bishop
on h3 is going to be hanging okay so f6
to blunt White's
attack
94 boris is not going to be denied takes
F Phi so this is like my conversation
with George to voinovich Bobby has
provoked Boris he is 1 upon Bobby took
of course ha ha ha
but we should be worried right I mean
there's a storm brewing around blacks
position and for example if we did
something conventional like eat aches
gf5 g5 we got to be worried about moves
like f6 check followed by Knight f5
check so there are some very serious
threats so how did Bobby meet these
threats I mean ah it's coming what did
Bobby Fischer play
okay so let's see so g5 one thing I
would be concerned about if I was black
if I played the mil g5 am I sure I can
handle rook takes d7 check and f6 yeah I
could take back with a king that looks
okay so maybe after g5 maybe I should be
fearful of f5 takes c6 with a knight
coming to f5 have you figured it out
yeah what's advise is what's a black
dude not sure come on
he has captured Bishop takes e4 it's the
most conventional wisdom in the world is
that when you're under attack you want
to trade off your opponent's attacking
pieces and this Bishop on b7 is a
beautiful Bishop you really don't want
to give it up needlessly but in this
case there was an Eden pretty good
Knight takes e4 this was a VI
I blew it I wanted to ask you guys this
was a really cool capture G takes G
takes and Bobby Knight f6 okay I mean at
the moment he's still upon up he's still
you know hanging on to that pond and in
the meantime if but if white pardon me
where to play Knight takes e4 Bishop
takes e4 takes on e6 Knight takes c6
Black's doing fine he's ready to jump to
d4 with the knight or perhaps to play
Bishop g5
rook g8 rook g1 pardon me attacking the
bishop on g7 check annoying you can
almost feel Boris Spassky venting his
frustration King takes g7 and now what
do you think is white battered what
should black - what should black to the
one okay so for example after say a move
like rook check let's say King e2 we
have we still have to deal with some
issues over here one thing that we could
think about perhaps is play the move
Knight takes e4 and just question after
Knight takes e4 rook takes g7 check King
comes to d6 and just question white
whether has two bishops and active rook
or full compensation for the pawn that's
one possibility we could go into
defensive mode and play a move like rook
check King e2 and move our King
but then after takes Bishop Knight takes
our pawn going to be hanging Bobby
Fischer
simple chess bishop f8
he didn't play rook check but kept his
rook on h8 for reasons we'll understand
soon enough
give me the knight on e4 Knight takes
King takes rook f11 takes rook takes
check King g7 so after all of that after
all of that action that Boris was trying
to create all the attacks what does he
have left to recapture his pawn bishop
came to d6 rook to e4 Bishop takes h2 so
now we start to understand why did Bobby
Fischer keep his rook on h8 because
rooks belong behind fast pause it's that
simple simple chest looks belong behind
pass pawn so he had 4 saw the outcome
now white really shouldn't have to money
too many troubles drawing this position
meanies upon down but the two bishops
are really a powerful compensation king
e to h5 rookie 7 check rook d7 Bishop e5
b3 h 4 ok so of course black has every
reason to play on but for the moment his
knight is a little bit stymied if the
knight moves the rook takes the pawn and
a draw it's more or less going to be
agreed so here we are at move 32 so if
you add the 50 moves from game Ron
essentially 82
great moves bye-bye Bobby but it gets
better his next moves you know I really
would think that most grandmasters
disposition would end in a draw
maybe black would only win just a tiny
fraction of the time 15% maybe King f3
rook g8 Bishop g4 h3 ooh that pawn is
slipping through Bishop takes h3 is met
by rook g3 check and taking the bishop
why did they did white what is sorry not
your wife here now now well he saw rook
g3 check was coming so he wanted to
block the check and at the same time
Boris had the idea that he would bring
his rook to h2 7 to get behind the
passed pawn Bishop g4 h3 rook h7 so in
his mind's eye what Boris was thinking
was that in this position he intends to
play Bishop f4 trade the defender of the
pawn on h2 and just pick up the pawn and
let's have a handshake and make a draw
nice plan but Bobby dinner great what
did Bobby do to make White's life
bring his knight into action so a move
like night II 6 definitely makes sense I
think this is where Bobby found a move
that I hadn't considered sorry bishop
before was played this is the move when
Boris was going through all of this
calculations that I think Boris reached
this position in his mind I said draw
draw
because Bishop takes and rook takes or
simply rook takes or Bishop takes and as
the gentleman said you know you can
bring your knight into play but after
trading everything you'll be in a drawn
working partner right so Boris had seen
all of this and thought draw but what
did Bobby play Bobby has a really really
cool move right here right now really
really cool move
you like King g6 as well okay so what
would be the idea of king g6 is that you
attack the rook if the rook takes this
pawn on h2 then okay so there's this
wonderful wonderful line I I'm not I'm
sure I think it was attributed Michael
tall but I'm sure he got it from
somebody else he's like if you see a
good move stop think there might be a
better one
so King g6 is a good move but stop think
is there a better one oh man
rook David eight okay so your idea is
maybe to give a check and so after
Bishop rook d8 Bishop takes King takes
rook takes maybe you're thinking that
maybe your king you would give a check
and maybe your king so there's one nice
idea of putting some pressure on on
black yes young lady
you thinking like Bobby Fischer rook F a
so this sets up a real nice threat of
king g6 and after Bishop takes e5 g g6
check King e4 King takes and this is
George stefanov itch Bobby one upon he
kept it of course
Bobby's one in exchange and I think
Bobby is winning Wow whoo so here we are
I what what move number is that over
there I mean he's just he's he's putting
pressure he's doing it he's doing it you
know the idea that Bobby could win again
and this is again it's at a time and age
where today you know the draw percentage
amongst grandmasters is pretty high 55
60 65 percent this is a guy who hasn't
played chess in 20 years who goes in
right out of the box and playing all of
these good moves okay it's still very
very difficult to win for black because
all the pawns are on one side and whites
King is very very active I mean it may
after for example a line where we move
our Knight to a6 that King could shoot
very quickly over to the Queen side okay
check first of all
Bobby tries to take advantage of the
fact that the night for the moment
protects the square d5 so he wants to
move blacks whites King away from the d5
square which he successfully did King f5
now I think him Knight d6
okay why didn't Bobby play Knight a six
by the way why would the a-two a-three
would keep the night certainly under
lock and key 96 of course so the night
heads for the center and Foursquare
where it'll be nicely anchored protected
as we say Knight d4 Lex moves all make a
very smooth progression yeah Bishop d6
so the idea behind this move from the
point of view of Boris Spassky if he
could just trade off all of these pawns
and get into a position where it B rook
and Knight versus two bishops he reckons
he might draw so with this move Bishop
d6 he's thinking that he'll play he'll
be able to play a move like B for one
day trade that c5 one day and so on so
Bishop d6 rook here Bishop here rook
down a for rook b3 Bishop b8 a5 Bishop
a7 rook takes b3 King here Knight check
King here knife here
Bishop here look you
okay so we reach the critical moment I
think King c6 was played literally Bobby
has played absolutely flawlessly to this
moment and another 50 moves have been
played
now when Bobby stopped playing chess in
1975 in that period you had what we
called adjourned
games so if the game wasn't finished by
say a move 40 the game was stopped the
position was recorded and the players
sealed their move
so Bobby really hadn't been in this
situation where he's now playing through
a finish so in this position this is
where Bobby let the win slip right here
what should Fischer do what should Bobby
Fischer play if you were black
what should Bobby Fischer play
don't all shout at once there is a
capture in the physician right of course
why not
Knight takes e4 and let's see what Bobby
calculated Bishop takes e4 rook takes e4
no Knight takes e4 in fact was the
winning move but Bobby got to this
position in his mind's eye and saw rook
takes a for King takes e5 and Bobby
knows full well that rook versus Bishop
is a draw but he didn't see how he was
going to hang on to his pawn okay I mean
it's clear that White's just going to go
King d5 and Bishop takes a five so you
have to move your rook away the King's
going to go to b5 he's going to take the
pawn the pawn goes to a 4
the bishop attacks the rook okay rook
attack ah sorry rook attacks Bishop
Bishop to c5 and this was the move that
Bobby had missed it was I meant to show
it
boy I'm terrible of year in the voting
the idea was that he saw this position
he anticipated rook a1 Bishop comes back
rook goes back a repetition he's missed
this cute move rook d5 give the guy some
credit it's the fifth sixth hour of play
he has played wonderful chess got this
winning position and miscalculated
simply put 94 Bishop c4 rook c4 Bishop
d6 rook 8th for king c5 rook a 1 king b5
a fork was winning for Bobby and it
would have been the fantastic
culmination of
of a flawlessly executed game Bobby
afraid that that variation would end in
a draw play 93 so his idea was that
after Part B his idea was that after
Bishop takes b6 Knight d4 check King
takes e5 Knight takes c6 you can't a
white cannot take the b6 pawn but on the
next move
Bobby had it in his mind that he was
going to take the pawn on a4 return his
rook to b4 and away she blows go go go
the a pawn boris has played Bishop d5
rook takes a 4
Bishop takes rook a 1 Bobby thought that
this was winning and you can't blame him
after 5-6 hours in terms of making one
believe that fat untalented other done
but he didn't anticipate is that when he
was going to be a whole rook ahead a
whole rook ahead but why could make a
draw he's going to be rook and Knight vs
Bishop and pawn but the king White's
King is going to support the C pawn the
way the game finished was Bishop takes a
for Bishop back a3 look of that pongo
but look at this pawn go white is going
to have to give up one of his bishops
for these for these pawns but he's got
enough counter play with his C pawn
check King rook takes Knight C to double
attack c6
so you've got your choice of how you
want to take which bishop it is that you
want to take but this pawn if you take
this bishop push you take this Bishop
King c6 and Queen making a draw if you
take this Bishop I think that's what
Bobby did I beg your pardon
yes if you take this Bishop Bishop d6
and Boris by the slimmest of margins
just it's enough to make a draw
actually my goodness I would really have
to check if this was a the final
position because I thought for some
reason that this move was played this
move this move for some reason I I had
it in my mind mmm that they played two
naked kings okay but it's possible that
the the input on the but it would be
amazing that they get this wrong I'm not
sure okay but that would have been how
the game had ended if they didn't agree
to a draw at that particular moment so
here it was very very astonishing but
the guy hasn't played for 20 years
came back played a hundred perfect moves
you can put it these two games through
your chess engine and see how many many
many many times
Bobby's Bobby's move was the first
choice of the engine
you